what are you doing on the rap side
you've been putting out some loosies
you've been throwing some singles out
there here and there I got some big [ __ ]
going you once again I had a [ __ ] I
had some balances that had to clear they
clear now but you know me and um
I'll just say me and Don Cannon got a
whole project it's almost done we that's
he's producing the whole day oh wow shot
the Don Cannon man
um so it's a Christian you feel me shout
out to krashawn you know what I'm saying
with maker sound and all that yeah okay
okay okay bro I didn't know if you just
told me you're gonna drop a collab BP
with croshan rock or not no no
I'm gonna say [ __ ] no but you know just
you and Don well I I heard some records
um somebody was playing I think it was
casting was playing me some oh yeah here
are some [ __ ] some [ __ ] that was like
crazy like just barring barring the [ __ ]
out it was like I was like [ __ ] but when
you hear me and Krishan [ __ ] shout out
to hit maker like yeah we got me a hit
maker croissant like this [ __ ] is out of
here would you do you feel like you're
doing like music now because you want to
not because you have to and does the
music get better there
um no I just feel like now I don't have
to force [ __ ] out I could I can put out
quality Take Time versus quantity
because you know I don't have to live
off for music no more right but that
wasn't the goal was to be just
successful you know what I'm saying
something yeah something just be just be
successful so it's like now and then too
like I hate people putting that stigma
on that you can only be great at one
thing of course or you can only be you
know the face of this and doing that and
it's like I look up to Ice Cube I look
up to Donald Glover where I'm like man
listen like Donald Glover you see him do
stand up you see him you know producing
a lot of times they do Atlanta yeah yeah
you could drop music you could do that
and it's and there's no ceiling for him
Ice Cube you feel me I mean you were in
Dave too yeah I was in Dave I'm actually
too man
um if this comes out in time I'm in the
new house party movie too I heard a lot
of people shout out to cow magic I heard
a lot of people are in that movie I'm in
the movie and I got a song in the movie
I heard a lot of people are in that
movie yeah so are you like are you gonna
try to dive into that side hell yeah
okay I'm doing everything yeah I think
you should write a sitcom or I'm doing
it oh bro I would love to do a sitcom
but yeah bro I just feel like
the sky's the limit like there's nothing
I can't do and even right now people
like they're like bro you killing that
podcast and killing it and streaming
like they may think this is my ceiling
this is not my ceiling right you feel me